this is a Fox News Alert president
Trump's attorney Michael Cohen has filed
a defamation suit against a BuzzFeed the
blog for publishing a dossier of
unverified allegations against Trump
last year Cohen told our Seraphin Gomez
at Fox quote I have filed the complaint
versus BuzzFeed and Ben Smith for the
lie filled dossier will continue to
follow those details and speaking the
dossier Fusion GPS co-founder Glenn
Simpson testified to Congress back in
August until now his remarks had
remained secret but today Dianne
Feinstein the Democrat of California
abruptly released a transcript of
Simpson's remarks and raises new
questions about the dossier during his
testimony Simpson said the FBI found the
dossier believable because it had a
source inside the Trump campaign who
provided corroborating information
Simpson also said that somebody or his
lawyer said someone had been murdered
due to the release of the dossier hmm
congressman Eric SWA was a Democrat
representing California and he joins us
and thanks coming up of course doctor I
see you're in California tonight and I
hope my parents take care of you there
they probably the only other
conservatives I'm having dinner with him
after the show speaking of I want to
give credit where it's due and I and
good for Diane Feinstein for releasing
this I think the public has a right to
know and I'm glad that that she did I
don't there are a lot of bomb shot I've
looked at it I don't think there are a
lot of bombshells but there is one point
that really sticks out and I'm wondering
what you make of it so in this testimony
Steele says that I mean rather simpson
says that Steele who's the agent he
hired on behalf of the Hillary campaign
spoke to the FBI which told him that
they had a source within the Trump
campaign and that that source
corroborated there was in a relation
between Russia and the Trump campaign so
here you have in the middle of a
presidential campaign September 2016 the
Obama FBI giving dirt on the Trump
campaign to Hillary Clinton's opposition
researcher I know you're a partisan
Democrat does that bother you at all
well no it was before it was the Obama
FBI it was the Bush FBI these are career
agents who serve this was I know but
hold on this was the controlled by the
Obama administration not control
just saying what do you make of that the
Obama FBI tells Hillary Clinton's
opposition researcher in the middle of a
presidential campaign in which she's
running that her opponents campaign has
connections to Russia I mean how is that
allowed in America well first I'll tell
you Tucker you know law enforcement
folks are quite offended by these
attacks calling it you know the Obama
FBI politics they don't care about
politics
some of them clearly do we know from
stocks texts to his girlfriend
some of them care a lot about politics
and there are open partisans some don't
I I agree I'm not attacking the whole
FBI but I'm saying that we have in the
release of this transcript evidence and
I think we both agree it's it's real
that the FBI told Hillary Clinton's
opposition researcher something negative
about her opponent that is not supposed
to happen is it well you know the FBI
usually keeps information on close hold
you know crystal steel was a you know as
I think this dossier lays out was a
pretty credible investigator for fusion
GPS I don't know what was exchanged
between Chris for stealing if yeah I
think we should know Tucker that those
are fair questions but what I think is
more working was working for fusion GP I
mean correct me if I miss dating this he
was still was working for fusion GPS
which was on retainer to the Hillary
campaign to dig up dirt on Donald Trump
campaigns do that both sides do it I get
it but he is in effect working as an
oppo researcher for Hillary Clinton's
campaign and the FBI is revealing
sources and methods to him in the middle
of a presidential campaign I just
stopped the presses and say what well I
think we stop the presses when
Christopher Steele stumbles upon
evidence that Donald Trump has a
financial relationship with Russia that
that to me is more concerning well maybe
I mean I'm sure Trump is I mean I don't
know the guy's been in business a long
time I mean I've look I have no idea but
the about his financial relationships
with various Russians I mean I don't
know I'm agnostic on it
it's a notes have been alleged a has
been proved true okay but I'm just
saying I know what it looks like when
politics subverts criminal justice and
that starts to happen when criminal
investigators who have vast
federal authority like the FBI start
talking to the Oppo researchers for
political campaigns in the middle of a
presidential year I mean that is just
absolutely over the top and what does
Bob Muller do he could have kept him or
throw him off the investigation he threw
him off I don't know what else you know
you'd want him to do he's gone know that
actually it sounds like entirely
possible at the FBI paid money to Fusion
GPS we don't know the answer to that
duty but it that's an open question it's
been alleged and they haven't really
answered the question aren't you let's
ask it and but let's also ask the
questions around what's allege in the
dossier and also there's a whole
mountain of evidence that has been
accumulated that's outside of the
dossier and so all of the arrows
continue to point to a personal
political and financial relationship
that Donald Trump had with the Russians
and whether it amounted to a crime or
not is Bob mullahs job
but I think we should do all we can to
make sure that this doesn't happen again
in the next election keep civil
liberties intact along the way
absolutely great congressman thank you
very much course my pleasure